it is Easter when many of us right now
would be in church and while most
churches have canceled services others
say they're gonna continue despite
government warnings or even threats and
now the Justice Department says it might
investigate any state or local
authorities that try to punish
churchgoers or their pastors Garret any
looking into both sides of this debate
that's been going on for all week hi
Garrett Hayley Linda the Attorney
General is warning state and local
governments that there could be
consequences for cracking down on
religious services in response to the
coronavirus on Saturday Easter Eve Bill
Barr spokeswoman Kari kupack tweeted
while social distancing policies are
appropriate during this emergency they
must be applied even-handedly and not
single out religious organizations
expect action from DOJ next week this
comes as a number of churches and
conservatives are pushing back against
local orders banning them from
worshiping in person on Saturday a
federal judge in Kentucky called the my
apologies he ruled that Louisville's
mayor cannot block a local churches
drive in Easter services US District
Judge Justin Walker called the mayor's
decision to ban all drive-in worship
services stunning and unconstitutional
riding in his decision that church goers
would face an impossible choice skip
Easter Sunday service and violation of
their sincere religious beliefs or risk
a risk arrest mandatory quarantine or
some other enforcement action for
practicing those sincere religious
beliefs former Arkansas governor and
Minister Mike Huckabee weighed in on
these fights earlier on Fox and Friends
I think some people have let power go to
their head and they're there shredding
both the Constitution and common sense
for example Pete why am i safer in a
Walmart with hundreds of shoppers than I
am in my own yard or in my car or by
myself at a church in a rolled car
rolled up windows listening to an FM
transmitter so I can hear the pastor
it's a different story in Kansas where
Saturday the state supreme court held a
videoconference hearing and ruled
favor of the state's Democratic governor
after Republican lawmakers tried to
block her order and limiting religious
gatherings to ten people following the
decision governor Laura Kelly tweeted
our response to this unprecedented
pandemic has necessitated that even our
most fundamental institutions find
alternative methods that preserve public
health now in Kansas like most other
states no religious leaders have
announced decisions to reopen their
doors their physical doors at least
however across the country there are
only a handful who have announced that
they will hold in-person services today
in defiance of state and federal
recommendations Leland we'll see how
that plays out today follow that
throughout the day and then obviously
what the DOJ does next week Garrett
thanks so much